california has become the first state
to implement an actual reparation scheme
for black people
we've talked about it for years
this goes back to that old promise of 40
acres and a mule for the freed slaves
that didn't happen there have been
in effect
a lot of reparations programs over the
years that's what that's what a lot of
the civil rights programs were about the
new society great society rather
programs were about that's what a lot of
the affirmative action programs were
about so there there has been a lot of
money spent on de facto
reparations but until now we haven't
really seen direct checks to black
people just for being black people
hundreds of years after slavery
well now we're seeing that in california
this california task force has has okay
reparations for direct descendants of
enslaved black people but but this
doesn't make a lot of sense
this doesn't one because people tend to
have mixed race and there were
black slavehold holders act
ironically the the first
officially determined owner of an
african slave for life in america was a
black guy himself was a black angolan
guy so
that it would be very difficult to parse
at exactly who gets the reparations but
moreover the argument from the left on
white supremacy and intersectionality
and critical race theory is that
racism and the effects of slavery
don't only affect the descendants of
black slaves it affects all black people
that if you are black in america even if
you got off an airplane from nigeria
just yesterday you are experiencing the
the problems and effects of white
supremacy and therefore you are owed
some kinds of reparations as well so
even by the left's own arguments
this this program doesn't make a lot of
sense but it's it's very clear what it
is it's it's a payoff it's a bribe it's
a bribe from the left to a very specific
interest group to a faction not a
political party
in the high-minded sense of having a an
understanding and an agenda for the
common good but just an interest group
and a faction you say we're going to pay
you a little bit of money and you vote
for us and that's how it's going to work
deeply on american deeply wrong stupid
generally and by the logic
of the left but that's the way our
politics is going right now go to
tessamays.com use promo code michael t e
s s e m a e
s.com promo code michael it's the
award-winning ranch dressing
vinaigrette
all sorts of american-made wonderful
delicious tasty healthy food it was
started by these three brothers who had
a dream to share their mom's recipes
with the world tessa maze puts flavor
and quality above everything else and
because of that they became the number
one organic dressing brand in
the country all the products are made
right here in the good old usfa they've
got a wide variety of kosher whole 30
and keto products whether you're in the
mood for a creamy avocado ranch or a
light refreshing lemon garlic dressing
and marinade there is a tessamese
product for every occasion everyone
agrees this thing tastes great on
everything dipping wings pizza pouring
it over a fresh salad tessa maze makes
every meal better these guys are the
embodiment of the american dream they're
bringing manufacturing back to america
their products are incredible go to
tessamays.com promo code michael get 15
off all their products
t-e-s-s-e-m-a-e-s dot com promo code
michael
i'm glad you like that clip now you
gotta subscribe ring the bell get all
the notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]